diamondback started tonight the
right-hander merrill kelly has lost
three straight starts but the d-backs
have scored a total bob of only five
runs in those three games merrill needs
to work on his hitting apparently uh
yeah he's done well enough to win his
last three starts unfortunately the team
just hasn't scored for him even though
he's pitched some of the best baseball
of his career over his last three here's
the birthday boy alex dickerson he's 31
today and that's strike three caught got
him looking nice chris one two three
inning finishing it with a cop third
strike to dickerson camaro kelly
on the hill tonight for the giants will
be the veteran right-hander johnny cueto
see what squado's done in six stars have
a little stint on the injured list good
start for the diamondbacks against plato
that'll bring up katel marte batting
second swinging a shot to right center
diamondbacks
going to get a lead i think here comes
the throw to the play by estrelski not
in time cut off one nothing on an rbi
single by marta and a really nice start
to this one a double and a single in a
one-nothing lead
it only took two batters it's one
nothing
josh
leads off with the double tell marta
waits on that off-speed pitch nicely
right there
flips it out into shallow right center
for mike destremski but rojas got a
great jump off second and scores easily
evan longoria
red hot right now big night last night
he walked he singled he doubled he homer
swing there's a line drive base hit
center field there's another one
they were swung over to the third base
side three infielders to the left of
second
and he hit it just to the right of
second a liner
ruff goes to second and holds on
to evan longoria with another
hard hit ball
here's mauricio devon now he steps in
with two on two out trying to
tie this game at least for the giants
and a fly ball to right for rojas he's
right there
he's got it two-handed catch stay in the
inning no runs kevin he hits two left we
go to the bottom of the second base hits
for four of the first seven diamondback
hitters against cueto two on no outs in
the second here's nick ahmed and that
one's going to bounce through
they will wave reddick
here's the throw from yastrimsky it is
not in time and it's two nothing
diamondbacks
rbi single for ahmed
scoring reddick for the second run of
the night for the d-backs it's
two-nothing
a lot of hits to that opposite field
pitch up and out over the plate for nick
and he tomahawks it through that right
side for an rbi base hit
[Applause]
that opposite field approach now rojas
now he's got an opportunity to knock in
a couple giants going to bring the
infield in here swinging in a basement
up the middle they'll score a couple in
is paving smith in his ahmed four
nothing diamondbacks
and a two-run hit right there for ross
who's two for two and two advance
against quito
boy nicely done with the infield in got
it hard enough right through the infield
base hit two rbis
that's already six hits for the d-backs
against kuwait
and four runs on the board evan longoria
leads off the fifth against merrill
kelly merrill has retired the last eight
giants he's faced called strike three
third strikeout for merrell who has set
down nine straight here's mike talkman
breaking ball did he go he did he's out
on a check swing strike three two up two
down back-to-back strikeouts for kelly
here in the fifth inning two down four
mauricio dubal and who's hit second base
tonight got him swinging
kelly strikes out the side five in the
ball game one two three go the giants in
the fifth eleven straight giants had
been retired since then until now so
here is yaz he's over two kazrinsky
lines this one down the left field line
and a fair ball it's going to roll
around where peralta picks it up and
duggar is going to be waived home and he
is going to make it and the giants are
on the board it's 4-1
so yaz he jumped on a two-seam fastball
it was running off the outside and man
talk about chucking it in just barely
fair that was inches fair inches on the
fair side of
the foul line
and the giants have their first run of
the game it's 4-1 arizona so now with
the infield back even a ground ball
could get a run home fastball ground
ball that'll get a run home but buster's
going to be thrown out by escobar the
third baseman moving to his left over in
front of shortstop he throws out buster
as
scores
two runs are in for the giants here so
here comes darren ruff swing line drive
base head left center field
toward the gap not hit all that hard
racing over his peralta to cut it off
now after a big turn around first ruff
puts the brakes on and goes back to
first and he might have hurt himself
doing that he did
he looked like oh right before he
started to stop
he was right
yeah he was in agony
foot on the brake hustle back to first
he's going to leave that's going to be
doubly frustrating he was all lined up
to get a lot of playing time at first
base with belts injured in last night's
game stefan got the loss sunday in
colorado
at least only one batter trevor story
and served up the walk-off homer swing
there's a liner down the right field
line that's a fair ball and it will
ricochet into the right field corner
right beneath the foul pole solano
digging for second and he'll stop there
with a double
creighton
been in 17 games and in 13 innings is
now allowed
11 runs and 19 hits
alex young
he and eric are under at second two out
8th inning 4-2 diamondbacks on top
there's slater coming to the plate swing
and there's a high drive down the left
field line way back there
adios
into the second deck
what a shot
and the giants have tied the game
austin slater
hits an emphatic home run
maybe the longest homer he has ever hit
in his career
he cleared the wall and left he cleared
the bullpen he cleared the lower deck
that was headed for sedona here now is
vassler bossler drives one down the
right field line it is out of here
and the giants take the lead how about
that the kid with a long at bat and he
finally got a pitch to pull and he yanks
it out of the park first big league
homer how about that
and it gives his team a lead another
two-strike approach they said an outside
target but it's 3-2 he didn't want to
walk him he gets in that strike zone at
92 with a little cut tyler rogers who's
going to try to close this thing out
well he's had seven opportunities he's
converted five saves look at the numbers
07-0 era in 25 games
time run is at third winning runs at
second rojas aboard it first escobar is
single in the fifth one for four here's
the pitch it's chopped over the mound to
crawford it's short he's got it first in
time and the ball game is over tyler
rogers gets out of the
it seems to be almost an impossible
scenario here